Object to all of the animals
in captivity.
Hi, how are you?
Good. How are you?
We're protesting the use
of animals in circuses here.
So, I hope you guys don't plan
on going to any animal circuses.
No, I don't like the circus.
It stinks.
Would you
consider yourself
the Black Panthers
of animal protesting?
You know what I'm saying?
I would say it's the civil-
rights movement for animals.
The civil-rights movement
for animals?
Yes, I think Martin Luther King
was an inspiration,
and if we could be the
Martin Luther King for animals,
why not, you know?
What?!
If you could be reincarnated
as any animal,
what would you be?
I'd probably choose
the wolf.
Well, if you were a wolf,
you would be eating sheep.
No, I'd probably make friends
with the baby lambs.
So, you're saying you would be,
like, a vegan wolf?
I'd probably be
a vegan wolf, yeah.
All right.
You ought to try
that good vegan diet.
You'll notice
a difference.
Yeah?
Yeah, the ladies
will notice a difference
without you pointing it out.
I swear to you.
My performance
is top-notch.
Oh, yeah? Well, imagine taking
it to even the next level.
There's not many women
that can handle that.
I eat absolutely
no animal products.
Animals think
other animals are delicious,
so why shouldn't I think
that they're delicious?
You know, pigs are
smarter than dogs.
That's why they taste great --
'cause they got a better diet.
They taste so good.
Is a palate
more important
than the life
of a sentient being that's born?
Yes. Yes.
Well, then,
you're not someone
I would ever ask to have
as a friend.
And I probably wouldn't want to
spend time with you, either,
'cause you'd be like,
"Why are you eating that?"
You'd keep saying
stuff like --
No, I live with two meat-eaters
my entire last four years,
and you can call
any one of them.
I never questioned
what they did.
I have respect
for people.
Wait.
You have roommates?
So, you don't think
there's a couple elephants that,
despite the abuse, they get
out there, they see the people,
like,
"It's my time to shine"?
Absolutely not.
Voilà!
You know what?
[ Laughter ]
If you could come back
as an animal, what would you be?
I used to want to be a dolphin,
but you know,
I don't know if you're aware
of the Taiji Cove.
No.
You guys need to see
the documentary "The Cove."
I haven't even watched
"Game of Thrones" yet.
I can't get into
dolphin documentaries.
Dolphins rape sometimes.
Have you googled that?
Yeah, I have, actually.
You're trying to protect
the dolphins?
Trying to protect
the dolphins, yeah.
Yeah, you got to get
your morals together, man.
Why? Why?
You single now?
I am not single.
I actually date
the elephant here.
You date the elephant?
Yeah.
Do you all ever do furry stuff
with that costume,
or would that be
disrespectful?
[ Laughs ]
That's a little weird.
Elephants are cool,
but not in the bedroom.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, you want an elephant
in the streets,
and a coyote
in the sheets.
Would you eat a plate of bacon
for $10 million?
No.
What?!
Somebody offered you
$10 million, would you eat eggs?
No, I wouldn't eat eggs
for $10 million.
You wouldn't eat eggs
for $10 million?
I wouldn't eat eggs
for $10 million, no.
I don't believe you.
A McNugget on a private jet
for $25 million?
No, no.
$12 million -- one piece
of Whole Foods Chilean sea bass.
No.
Would you eat a piece of chicken
for $50 million?
I think I would have to
be presented with the money
and know
that that was real.
[ Bell dings ]
HANNIBAL:
Yeah, so, it was a good day.
I learned a lot about the abuse
of animals in the circus.
I learned a lot
about vegan culture.
Very informative day.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]